Now that we've explored how
to display points on the map,
we can give the user more
information about those points.
Info windows are pop-up displays
which are shown at a given location,
either with or without a marker.
They're great for giving contexts,
such as text describing a location,
or showing images related to it.
Creating an info window works
very similarly to the marker
in that we'll use an object and
several basic parameters.
Creating a new info window instance only
requires that we put some content into
the info window, a string or
a pre-defined set of elements.
The info window though, unlike
the marker, won't open automatically.
We need to add one more thing to
tell it when and where to open.
We're adding an event listener so
that the info window only opens
when we click on the market.
Within the event listener,
we'll call the info window.open method.
Passing in the map on which to open, and
optionally, the marker
on which to anchor it.
If we didn't pass in a marker,
we would need to give the info window
a position property so
that it has a place to open.
So if we click on the marker,
we can see our lonely info window.
But we want to show a whole
bunch of locations.
We don't want to show
the user just one house.
I'm going to delete our single
point marker and info window.
So here we've created an array of
objects with some listing titles, and
a bunch of lat longs in
the initialize function, so
that we have all of the information
we need in the browser.
In your own projects,
we'd recommend using a database, and
serving the information to your site.
There are a bunch of features of
the API that allow you to easily render
large amounts of data onto your map.
You can read more about them in
the link, in the instructor notes.
For now,
since we only have a few points,
we're just going to keep
the data in the browser.
Now instead of creating one marker,
we'll make a whole bunch of
them out of this information.
We'll add a blank marker array globally,
since we'll have only one of these for
the listings in our site.
Then we'll loop through the locations
we created in order to create one
marker per location.
We'll keep each newly created marker
instance in the markers array to keep
them organized.
Now, we want an info window to appear
when any one of the markers is clicked,
and we want the content
to reflect that marker.
So we'll add an on click
event to each marker.
We'll make a separate function,
passing in the marker that was clicked,
which is, this.
And the info window that we
created on initialize here.
This function is essentially
going to tell the info window to
open at that marker, and populate with
information specific to that marker.
We'll create this function below.
Each time one of our
listing markers is clicked,
this populate info window
function is going to be called.
Essentially, all this is doing is
setting the content of the info window
to the marker's title, and
opening the info window on that marker.
Finally, we may have listings that
are outside the initial zoom area and
we want to be able to adjust the
boundaries of the map to fit everything
that we want the user to see.
So we'll create a new
lat long bounds instance
which captures the southwest and
northeast corners of the view port.
Then we'll extend it for
every marker that we make.
And finally, we'll tell the map
to fit itself to those bounds.
Voila, we have a very
basic listings app.
If I click each marker,
a brief description of the listing
shows above that marker.
Once you can do that, there's
a crazy number of things you can do.
Change your markers to be custom icons,
put images, links,
and other information into
the info windows, and more.
If I wanted to, I could change all of my
markers to be pictures of Ajays head.
But on a serious note, let's make one
more improvement before we move on